hi everyone it's me danny ceo and
welcome to do
just one thing
and you know that slogan put a cork in
it well how about 50
wine corks to make a really cool
upcycling project what we're going to
make today
is we're going to take your collection
of wine corks and make
a beautiful trivet for your kitchen and
you won't believe how simple
and easy it is it's actually a one step
craft project
even though it looks really beautiful
and complicated you don't need any
special tools you don't need any glues
or adhesive all you need
is a flathead screwdriver and maybe the
fun part is about
50 wine cork so i guess step one really
is drink a lot of vino this summer
and then save your wine corks the way
that this works is that we're going to
use something called
tension to keep everything in place and
this is the one investment you have to
make it comes in a lot of different
sizes
it's called a hose clamp it's a metal
hose clamp you find at the hardware
store it's in the plumbing section this
large one
cost about two dollars and they come in
smaller sizes you can make a small
coaster you can make a medium-sized
trivet or you can make an extra large
one like this one
and the way that it works is that all
the way on the side right here there's
like a flathead little screw right here
and then by twisting it it actually gets
tighter and tighter and tighter and
smaller and smaller
so the fun part is you take your wine
corks
and you simply place them all the way on
the
inside of the hose clamp and it's kind
of fun to do this because what you want
to do
is create a pattern and make sure there
aren't any gaps or any spaces in between
the corks
and you can do this with champagne corks
if you're going to a summer wedding
here's a fun idea why not save all of
the corks from the wedding and surprise
the married couple with a trivet that
she made using corks from the wedding if
you're one of those people where you're
like danny
how the heck am i going to drink 50
bottles of wine which
to me this seems reasonable but if
you're wondering how am i going to drink
50 bottles of wine my little inside
trick is
go to a local restaurant that maybe has
a wine bar
and bring a box or a bag and ask them
could you save the wine corks for me
so usually they're not saving them for
anything else and they'll happily save
them for you and you'll get
hundreds and hundreds of corks very
quickly and easily
so as you can see you want to fill the
entire thing up with wine corks i'm just
going to put these aside
to show you what the finished one looks
like here's the finished one
really really beautiful and if you find
that it's a little bit loose
you just take your flathead screwdriver
and you tighten it
and you can hear it like you can hear it
tightening around it
and it's all that tension that keeps
all these wine corks in place then you
put it on your kitchen countertop and
the next time you have a scorching hot
pan
just place it on top and it's completely
protected
one step project using wine corks do
just one thing
be sure to tag the drew barrymore show
in your instagram post and don't forget
to check out more projects at
thedrewberrymoreshow.com
and one more thing be sure to pick up
the newest issue of my magazine
naturally danny ceo
[Music]